i don't know if you're familiar with
gayle's like
incompleteness theorem i'm not
unfortunately okay
it was a powerful proof
that next semantic systems when you
start from a bunch of axioms
that there will in that system
provably must be an inconsistency
so that was this painful like stab
in the idea of mathematics that no
if we start with a set of assumptions
kind of like adrian started
with objectivism there will have to be
at least one contradiction yeah
i intuitively am going to say that's
false philosophically but
in math it's just true
and that's it's a question about how you
define again you
definitions matter and you have to be
careful how you define axioms
and you have to be careful about what
you define as an inconsistency and what
that means
to say there's an inconsistency and i
don't know i'm not going to say more
than that because i don't know
but i'm suspicious that
there is some uh and this is the power
philosophy and this is why
i said before concept formation is so
important and understanding causes of
formation is so important from for
particularly getting mathematics because
it's such an abstract field
and it's so easy to lose grounding in
in reality that that
if you properly define axioms and you
properly define what you're doing in
math whether that is true and i
i don't think it is this is uh yeah
we'll leave it as an open mystery
because
actually this audience you know there's
literally over a hundred thousand people
that have phds and
so they they know gato's the complaints
theorem i i have this intuition
that there is something different to
mathematics and philosophy
that i'd love to hear from people like
what what exactly is that difference
because there's a precision to
mathematics
that philosophy doesn't have
but that precision gets you in trouble
it somehow it actually takes you away
from truth
like the the very constraints of the
language used in mathematics
actually puts a constraint on that on
the capture of truth that it's able to
do so i'm going to argue that that is
a comp a total product of the way you're
conceptualizing
the the terms within mathematics it's
not in reality
yes so it's you would argue it's in the
fact that mathematics
in in as much as is detached from
reality that you can do these kinds of
things
yes and and your and you've and that
mathematicians have uh
come up with concepts that
they haven't ground it in reality
properly that allows them to go off
on on in places that have they don't
lead to truth that's right that don't
lead to truth
but i encourage you then i encourage you
to
to to do one of these uh podcasts with
one of our philosophers
who know more about uh about this stuff
um
and if you if you move to austin i've
got somebody i'd recommend to you
and can you throw a name on or no yeah i
mean i would i would i would talk to
greg so mary
when we say our can you say what you
mean by hour
i'd say people who are affiliated with
the admin institute
are philosophers who are affiliated with
objectivism
right and greg is one of our one of our
brightest and and he's in austin
he's just got a position at ut uh so at
the university of texas
uh and he and he would want on kagate
would be another one who actually works
at the institute and a chief philosophy
officer at the institute
that's awesome and uh and there are
others who specialize
in philosophy of science who who i think
greg could probably
uh give you a lead but but these are
unbelievably smart people who know
this part of the philosophy much better
than i do
you